khan academy students what's going on
it's akbar baja biamilla host of
american ninja warrior
i just wanted to check in with you guys
but also to wish you a
happy new year it's 2021.
things are going to be a lot different
and i know in 2020
things got crazy right we had the
isolation and a lot of us were
struggling going through the ups and the
downs and
things at home were starting to change
because of coven 19.
well this is a new year a new mindset
and as you can see
i'm inside of my office and you can see
some of my football jerseys
and what i love about football what i
love about american ninja warrior
is that you constantly have obstacles
that you have to overcome
that is going to happen regardless if
it's a
good year or a bad year that we saw and
i put in quote because that's all
relative
that we saw in 2020. so
my coach used to tell me this and i
truly do believe this is that
tough times don't last but tough people
do and to be tough what does that mean
does that mean you have to growl like no
what it means is that you're willing to
accept the challenges
that are in front of you you're willing
to go with the ups
and the downs but you're also knowing
that you have this trajectory
you're going up so to the khan academy
students
i say this to you be an american ninja
warrior
in the classroom at home during your
personal life
whatever it is that you're going have
that mindset that is that i will
overcome you're going to overcome
whatever those obstacles
and then when i see you at that buzzer
when you get up that warp wall in life
in school and in your personal life and
you hit that buzzer i'm gonna say
i see you i see you hitting that buzzer
so
take on 2021 with a new mindset a new
attitude
don't look in the past it's just
something for you to reflect
and move forward i'll leave you with
this
take every stumbling block in school in
life
and whatever and turn it in to a
stepping stone
you got that stumbling block into a
stepping stone
that's your challenge for 2021 all right
you guys are khan academy ninja warriors
have a great school year and we'll talk
soon